[Music]
man I see a Fight Club the strongest and
smartest man who've ever lived
I see all this attention
is one
God damn it an entire generation pumping
gas
waiting tables
slaves with white columns
advertising has chasing cars and clothes
working jobs we hate so we can buy
we don't need
[Music]
for the middle children of History man
no purpose or place
[Music]
we have no Great War
no Great Depression
our Great War is a spiritual war
How Great Depression
is our lives
but I get concerned every time I watch
it
concerned because I don't know if a
movie can predict future events or if
the movie itself can become the Catalyst
for the emergence of those events
modern societies seem unable to offer
the level of meaning demanded by our
complicated nature we seek and we find
as we seek again and we find again
in the end we rarely discover answers
that can truly satisfy our curiosity
the next question is bigger than the
last one and the lack of proper
explanations creates an intellectual and
spiritual void
this void becomes an extension of our
Persona and manifests itself in
behaviors that connote moral relativism
and a deep anger towards our creator
the more dissatisfaction we experience
the more the void grows bigger
it grows bigger until it transforms into
a merciless pit that will swallow us all
the dawn of Consciousness was a very
mistake or a gift no one can really tell
it was a gift because we are now able to
be in absolute control of our world it
was a mistake because we have no idea
why we do what we do
the aimless pursuit of goals dreams and
Visions can keep one alive but it
doesn't necessarily make this life
pleasurable
at the end of the day every self-aware
person realizes that our war is
spiritual and that our depression is our
lives
through spiritual practices we can
reframe the context of their lives we
decide to lead and eventually ameliorate
our experience
exist more in our heads than in reality
you're always thinking and erratic
behaviors that are constantly showcased
in mainstream media and are consequently
adopted by social agents are nothing
more than a distraction
heterodox approaches can act as a life
jacket within a spiritually dry
landscape
whilst in spiritual mode you can more
closely examine the melody of the cosmos
this the sparkling allegories of nature
the biggest truths of The Human
Condition wrapped in the hard shell of
nonsensical abstraction
themes that flow through the air with
the greatest of ease outside of that
state you're just deaf and lost in their
ubiquitous noise of everyday dribble
[Music]
when you succeed in silencing the noise
and allowing the signal to pass through
the cosmos can reveal all its Secrets
all the nuances of every element that
might seem insignificant throughout the
conventional narrative ceases its
insignificance and it morphs into pure
cosmic energy
you close your eyes and you just listen
and feel
the darkness starts to take shape and
weird patterns slowly merge
what you experience doesn't make sense
Your Capacity to understand is based
solely on intuition
this is how you connect with the unknown
the chaotic nature of the cosmos seems
so seductive and inviting that you can't
resist
it is this state that you have been
seeking for so long
its Essence sounds like poetry to your
Carlo years
you lack knowledge but your intuition
seems enough you try to understand where
are you what's your purpose what is this
to which the cosmos replies it is you
it is a response so simple yet so
profound that it has completely painted
over the canvas of your mental imagery
you are the anthropomorphic
manifestation of the cosmos expressing
itself in a poetic way
[Music]
foreign
mmm Shanti